Japan is a remarkably safe society
crime rates are low on the state
incarcerates far fewer people than in
other rich countries
the emphasis is on rehabilitation and
rates of recidivism are low but when
people are accused of a crime they are
almost always convicted
kazooie Ishikawa was convicted of murder
in 1964 he signed a confession statement
after 30 days of interrogation even
though he was illiterate at the time oh
there's us a story
wat si Saket raw honey and escarole
testimony gos I'm not in this Corral
Akane is rotor America today's demo Muji
Sonoma no mas no hi diva Mary Martha you
husband and I know they're so new Tajima
total cholesterol
Jim you owe me a coke you mean denial on
us a great Oh
da-da-da-da-da Rama kokoro Cataumet a
divorce
certainiy cemetery mess
mr. Ishikawa said he was eating dinner
with his family at the time of the crime
the police said that their statements
could not be used as evidence because
there were his family in Japan convicted
people like mr. Ishikawa have a little
chance of getting their guilty verdicts
overturned 98% of Appeals in serious
cases fail because they are either
dismissed the requests of retrial are
retracted or the accused passed away
Japan does not have juries instead a
panel of judges decides whether the
accused is guilty since 2009 civilians
have acted as lay judges in some cases
prison life is draconian talking is
prohibited for most of the day and
reading is only sometimes allowed death
row inmates can wait in solitary
confinement for many years they are also
not told when they would be executed a
wake up each morning not knowing if it
is their last mr. Ishikawa was on death
row for ten years before his death
sentence was commuted to life in prison
he thinks this was because evidence had
accumulated in his favor the Justice
Ministry is unable to discuss the
details of the case
Yahoo Novara Asano hot Suzuka da Jun is
rotten no Jonny
skyress corner okay Nagato Barack you
can juice Mata Hari massive matter to
Cairo Jim Gangaram a cenote
mino-san skill karo skin Latrice wah
good into a harrenhal moisture city -
Martin's know a decimal so a task says
Artemis
you
hey baby hey let's go down there
Oh Akane let the husband's in
enterovirus Yokohama please ask akka
Cristobal to neutralize the pseudo-code
a servo motor glottis images to
photography Northman's la siroque is
Derek start a hotel como Garson cos OTO
Co today at Marcos de cive our Connie
chaos Carlton Street
choco Hardison you need to put on your
service
you